- [Ayesha] Okay, I'm gonna kickstart.
- [Jack] Yep. I think we're good to go.
- A very good evening, everyone.
(audience chattering faintly)
A very good evening and a warm
welcome to each one of you
who has taken the time to
attend our session today.
I know you had a lot of
sessions to choose from,
so I'm really grateful you've
taken the time to come here
and attend our session, and we
promise you a very fun-filled
and a very learning experience
in the next one hour.
Before I begin,
I wanna make sure all of
you have your headsets on,
and also you can hear me.
If you can hear me, can you
please raise your hands?
Okay, perfect. Awesome, awesome.
So with that being said,
I do wanna share that
whether you are a CX leader
or a business owner
who's looking for your next
big strategic transformation,
or an IT architect who's working
on the next school solution
and is trying to build that,
or whether you are an
innovator who's just curious
to learn about AI
and how we can apply that
in customer experience,
I believe you all have the
same question on your mind,
"How do we truly apply personalization
in customer experience,
and we scale that to tens
and thousands of customers?"
Today, in this session, I
am gonna walk you through,
along with Jack, how
AI-powered Amazon Connect
can help you achieve exactly that.
Quick introduction. My
name is Ayesha Borker.
I'm a principal solution architect
specializing in Amazon Connect.
And with me, I have Jack.
- I'm Jack Hutton.
I'm a principal product
manager of Amazon Connect,
specializing at agent AI.
- And in the next one hour,
we will be walking you
through these main five themes
across personalization.
The first is why is
personalization even important?
We will also touch upon
how Amazon Connect helps
you achieve personalization
for your end customer use cases.
And then, we will also touch
upon real customer results,
customers who have delivered
personalized experiences in production
and the business outcomes
that they've achieved today.
I promise you, and I'm very confident,
that at the end of this session,
you will have learned a lot,
and you will see a lot of the cool tools
that Amazon Connect has launched recently,
that you can use and go back and implement
into your contact center too.
With that being said, I actually
wanna start with a story,
A story of personalization
gone horribly wrong.
So there's a very famous movie quote
that life is like a box of chocolates
and you never know what you're gonna get.
So this is from a time,
during my last birthday,
when I would received a box of chocolates
as my birthday gift, and I
wasn't expecting that at all.
The reason being, last
year was also the year
I jumped on the bandwagon of being fit
and joining a gym as well.
More importantly, I was also
extremely vocal about it.
I made sure everyone around me knew
that I'm trying to be fit,
I'm lifting kettlebells,
I'm eating my salads.
Every social gathering that I went to
was all about my fitness journey.
And yet when my birthday arrived,
a very dear close friend
of mine decided to give me
a box of chocolates.
I guess by now, you know what went wrong.
I kept giving my friend
all the information she
needed to know about my life,
and yet the decision she made
to gift me had nothing to do
with any of the information or
data that I provided to her.
A quick show of hands,
any one of you have
been in a similar space,
received a gift you are not?
Well, how does that make
you feel? Invisible, right?
Ironically, a lot of organizations
and businesses today are
making the same mistake.
Your customers are constantly giving you
a lot of information about themselves.
They're going to your website,
they're clicking on certain items,
they're accessing your web app,
they're calling you in
your contact center,
they're telling you what their problem is,
and yet organizations
and businesses are not
trying to use that data
and deliver a personalized experience.
I wanna share some
interesting statistics here.
So, McKinsey did a survey,
and they said that 76% of
consumers are more likely
to consider purchasing from
brands that personalize.
Again, how many of you agree?
How many of you would go and shop
if a business actually near you
and would have a higher
propensity to check out?
Perfect. I agree with you as well.
The other data that I
have is that organizations
that implement personalization
are realizing 10 to 15% lift in revenue.
The good news is that personalization
lives in Amazon's DNA.
Amazon has 25 years of learning
and innovating just on personalization.
So in 1998, we launched our
first recommendation engine
that simply said, customers
who bought X item in your cart
also tend to buy by Y.
That was a simple AIML
model, but over the years,
we've learned, we've churned,
and we've improved this model
to deliver even more sophisticated
and unique experiences,
not only across channels,
but also across devices
and machine learning.
And the good news is we are now bringing
similar learning models
and infrastructure to you
so that you can deliver the
same kind of experiences
for your users using Amazon Connect.
I just wanna give you one
example of personalization.
Anyone here who has
explored Help Me Decide?
Okay, we have one person,
but Help Me Decide is a
product recommendation feature
that Amazon has run recently in the app.
So if you're trying to buy something
and you don't know which
one should you buy,
I'm always in that position,
I'm always someone who
can never make a decision,
but Help Me Decide will
basically tell you,
let me load, how it works.
Let's say you're
searching for tea kettles,
and then it starts finding
the best option for you,
personalized based on your usage,
your product history,
and your recommendations.
And it gives you three options, right?
The upgrade pick, the
best of recently viewed,
and also the budget pick.
So Help Me Decide actually
makes it really easy.
It removes the mental load
of your end consumers,
and what's the right decision for them,
and what they should shop,
and what they should end up buying.
So I know all of this
sounds amazing, right?
Personalization is
critical, it's important,
but why is there still a gap?
Why are most organizations
still struggling
to deliver personalization?
I think the problem is
broadly in two categories.
The first is data. I spoke
to you about that, right?
Your consumers are
giving you a lot of data.
How do you unify that data?
That's the fundamental problem.
However, the emerging problem
that we are seeing is,
I have the data, what do I do with it?
How do I know what's the
right recommendation?
How do I know I, how do
I pair the right product
with this recommendation?
And how do I deliver that
experience to my customer?
So these are the twofold problems
that we are looking to
solve with Amazon Connect.
How many of you here have
heard of Amazon Connect?
Okay, most of you have,
but for anyone who hasn't,
Amazon Connect is basically
our cloud-based contact center,
which is one application
that provides you one seamless experience
across all channels
with routing, analytics,
inbound, outbound agent,
and supervisor experience.
Within Amazon Connect, we
are now launching agentic AI
that enables personalized
customer experiences.
So tying back to the two problems
that I called out earlier,
the first is unification of customer data.
How do you make sure your customer data
that comes from different channels,
including your contact
center, your websites,
is unified in a singular customer profile?
Okay, now what do I do with that data?
So this is the gen AI insights,
which we will be focusing
a lot more on today.
The first thing is having a
specialized AI sales agent.
This is something you can build,
and I'll also be showing
you a demo of later today.
The second is segmentation.
How can I provide gen
AI insights on the data
and the unified profiles I already have?
And then, obviously, you
wanna measure the outcomes
and you want to analyze
the kind of information
and the insights you are delivering
in your customer experiences
so that you can come
back and improve upon it.
And then lastly, it's the
customer engagement layer.
Once you have the profile,
the gen AI insights,
how do you deliver that,
either in customer service,
proactive outbound engagement,
your web app, or your mobile apps?
So I just wanna go back to the AIML models
that I was talking about,
which Amazon.com has been using for years.
And now we are launching five
similar algorithms for you,
out of the box in Connect,
that you can build you within an AI agent
and deliver in a customer experience.
So the first is Recommended for You.
Recommended for You is a
one-on-one personalization.
This model tends to know your customer
on a one-on-one basis.
What does Jack like? What do
I really recommend to Jack?
So that's the crux of that model.
The second is Similar Items.
This model will help you
deliver the perfect alternative.
What if your customer's
here to buy a new T-shirt
and you're out of the T-shirt?
How do I provide them
a perfect alternative,
a similar item so that they feel like,
"Yeah, this seems like
something I would buy too,"
and then go ahead and make that purchase.
The other is Frequently Paired,
which is your classic upsell
and cross-sell algorithm.
So if a customer has a high
propensity for shopping,
let's say, pet food items,
they probably are also shopping
for pet dirt bags, right?
So something of that sort, you
can frequently pair the items
and you can provide it to your customers.
And then Trending Now is
your classic algorithm
for what's trending, what's hot now,
what is every customer buying,
and how do you deliver
that to your end user?
And the last one is Popular Items,
which is, what are your
popular items in general,
what are your consumers buying from you,
and how do you provide that
to your end users using this algorithm,
either through the medium of the AI agent
or directly in your websites?
And then finally, what's
the real outcome, right?
I have these algorithms.
What are the outcomes
that I'm going to achieve?
Increase in revenue? Increase
in customer lifetime value?
And then decrease in abandonment, right?
Where your customers are coming in,
they don't see what they like,
it's a hard time to figure out
what they even want to purchase from you,
and then they just abandon your cart,
and then they leave you.
That was a lot of talk. Let's
see some of this in action.
So I'm gonna show you a quick demo
of an agentic powered
personalized interaction
using all of these AI
features that I just spoke of.
So we are gonna start with
our first persona, Priya.
She's a revenue growth
manager at AnyCompany Retail.
And her challenge is
that they're now entering
the summer season.
They've launched a summer collection,
and she needs to do an outbound campaign
that's personalized and reaching
to the right people, right?
So she's saying, "Hey, I
wanna identify the customers
who are likely to attend
special events this summer
and are more likely to buy
our summer collection."
And she wants to do a
more personalized campaign
and not a generic mass campaign.
So how does she do this
with Amazon Connect?
Within Amazon Connect,
we have customer segmentation
and customer trends.
So using your customer profile data,
you automatically get the customer trends
available on your screen.
Priya likes the summer events
collection launch trend,
and she starts seeing a segmentation,
which is a list of customers
who have a high propensity of buying
if she launches this campaign.
She also has the capability
of entering a prompt
that show me customers who've purchased,
occasion where more than three
times in the last 18 months,
and who are high-valued customers.
Once she likes what she sees,
she can go ahead and create an
automated outbound campaign.
It's a simple step to create a campaign.
She just has to click on
a few options on the UI.
She chooses to launch an email campaign.
And once she likes what she sees,
she puts in the time zone,
the communication time,
and then she just clicks on Publish.
So very simple.
Just in a few steps,
Priya has used AI to find the right target
and segment of customers
she needs to reach out to,
and she's gone ahead
and created a campaign
in the communication
channel of her choice,
when in this case was email.
Now let's see what happens next, right?
Now the moment has arrived,
we have our next persona, which is Maya.
So she's a frequent high-value customer
of AnyCompany Retail, and
she's having a Saturday coffee,
and she just received a
personalized notification that,
you know, there's a
summer collection launch
and she thinks it's perfect timing,
so let's see what happens next.
So she receives an email
that "Your Summer Collection Awaits,
we are giving you a 15% off."
And she can also chat with Stella,
which is an AI agent or an AI stylist
that AnyCompany retail has
built on Amazon Connect
along with the FY algorithm models
that I was talking about earlier.
And I'm gonna show you what happens
when Maya starts interacting with Stella.
So Maya logs into the app,
she browses on the app,
she's looking at some items, right?
She's looking at a champagne
silk dress, a navy midi dress.
So before I play out the
demo, I just wanted to share
that she's browsing
through a lot of items,
so we are capturing these clicks,
which is a part of the profile,
and now we are going to use those clicks
to give her a more
personalized recommendation.
So Maya is just browsing,
she's gonna scroll down,
and then she's also gonna start
an interaction with Stella,
who's the AI stylist that's
built on Amazon Connect.
So Stella recognizes her and says,
"I noticed you were looking
at the champagne silk dress.
Are you shopping for a special occasion?"
And Maya says, "Yes, for
a wedding next month."
So Stella wants to know, "Tell
me more about the wedding.
Where is service of wedding?"
So, apparently, it's an
outdoor wedding in Napa Valley
and she wants a cocktail attire.
So this is where the
product recommendation
algorithm kicks in
and provides personalized
options to Maya, like,
"Hey, if you're looking for a wedding,
which is an outdoor wedding,
maybe these three are the best options."
So Maya does like the
champagne silk dress,
so she's gonna say, "Yes, I love that one,
but do you recommend some
shoes to go with that?"
So this is where the
frequently paired algorithm
comes into picture, and
says, "That's a great choice.
And guess what? Customers are
buying block heel sandals,
maybe a necklace.
Do you wanna go for that?"
Maya says, "Yes, I love that idea,
but there's also a rehearsal dinner.
So do you recommend something
more casual for that?"
So the AI stylist now is just
providing the top trending
or popular items,
which is the other algorithm
I was talking about,
and makes a recommendation to Maya.
So Maya says, "Okay, I
think I've had enough.
I've blown out my budget now,
so that's the only thing I'm gonna shop,
but can I get some discount?"
So once again, the AI stylist,
based on AI recommendations,
is proposing the Insider
applied program to Maya,
which she chooses to enroll in
and get some more, 38,
I think a 15% discount
on her retail order.
Finally, Maya says,
"I've had enough, I've
shopped these items,
but I do wanna get an alteration
on my previous order."
So to do that, the AI stylist says,
"Okay, I'm gonna transfer
you to the right agent,
and I'm also going to
transfer all of this context
to the agent as well."
So let's look at the agent experience.
How are we, how is Agent
AI helping the human agents
deliver a personalized
experience to customers too?
So for anyone who's not seen this before,
this is the Amazon Connect
agent workspace out of the box.
We have Agent Jordan
who's just received a chat
coming in from Maya, with
all the context and history,
her customer details showing
up using customer profiles.
And then Jordan is also looking
at Maya's profile explorer,
once again, an out of the box feature
within customer profiles.
It uses AI to analyze Maya's profile,
give her overall customer value,
and also give her overall
customer satisfaction scores.
Some of the next steps,
recommendations that the
AI assistant is providing,
that "Hey, probably Maya is asking
about the previous order history.
Let's go and review her order history."
And also, probably ask
her a few questions,
"Hey, which is the dress that
you wanted alteration on?"
And once Maya suggests that,
Jordan seeks the help of
an AI agent on the right,
that "Hey, is this customer
eligible for a free alteration?"
So the AI agent accesses
knowledge articles
which are available in the backend
and integrated with Connect,
and says, "Yes they are.
And why don't you use
this step-by-step guide
and just follow the steps
and provide Maya the free alteration
and also book her appointment
for the alteration as well?"
So as you see, in just a few clicks,
the human agent was
also empowered to use AI
to provide the right
personalization to Maya
and address her query
within just a few seconds.
So that's more going from segmentation
to seeing the AI agent in action.
But let's also talk about
observability, right?
We have our AI agent, it's out there,
it's helping customers,
but how do I know as a supervisor
that it's doing the right job for me?
So this is where we wanna
close the performance loop.
So, Priya, back to Priya,
she's launched this campaign,
it's run for a few weeks.
Now she wants to know how
effective her campaign was,
and was the AI agent effective at all?
Once again, we have recently
launched automated evaluations
for your AI agents as well.
So Amazon Connect always had evaluations
for your human agents,
but now you can also
evaluate your AI agents.
So in this screen, you can see
you have a unified dashboard
of your self-service AI performance,
how many contacts are going
through the self-service AI,
how many active AI agents,
also the AI coverage by
contact categories, right?
How many were using the shopping stylist,
how many were contacting
for returns and refunds?
And then you also get a trend
of the AI agent performance tools.
You can also see invocation by latency,
and there's just a lot more rich data
that's available out of the box.
You also get detailed contact records.
So in this case, you can
see an evaluation score,
not just for the human agent
but also for the self-serve agent.
And on the on your right and my left,
you can see the overall
evaluation score of the AI agent
and the self-service success
and the customer experience.
And in this case,
apparently the AI agent
did a very great job.
It did an upsell and it had a 90% score.
So that's more on the
out-of-the-box features
on how you can evaluate your AI agents.
But as always, all of
this data is available
in the raw format as well.
So if you wanted to build
your own custom dashboards
using Amazon QuickSight,
you could also create a campaign metric,
which Priya is using right now,
where can she can see how
many emails were sent,
how many emails were opened,
what was the revenue that she's achieved,
either through the email, opening the app,
browsing, the whole journey
of the customer, right?
And eventually, leading to membership.
And you could also create dashboards
for multi-channel performance,
how you're performing in your apps,
how you're performing in your emails,
and what's the relevant revenue
associated with each of those channels?
And also, your top AI agent actions.
How are your product
recommendation algorithms working?
How are your upsell algorithms working?
So those are the kind of
insights that you can provide
to tie back to real business outcomes.
With that being said,
let's talk about some
real business outcomes.
So for that, we have Jack,
who will take it forward from here.
- Thank you.
Yeah, so those demos you just saw
weren't art of the possible.
These all demonstrated what's
available in Connect today,
mostly out of the box with
some minor customizations.
And so to help illustrate that,
we have four customer examples
of production workloads
taking Connect's capabilities
and providing personalized outcomes.
Now these examples range from
four different industries
and a bit of some overlaps
in some of the features,
but mostly different parts of Connect,
all for the common goal
of delivering great personalized
outcomes for the customers.
So we're gonna start with
Saks Global and GoStudent
to sort of compare and
contrast the similarities
of how they use Connect.
So, Saks Global is a
international luxury retailer
with both a historic and
iconic physical presence
with Saks Fifth Avenue
as well as an e-commerce
division launch in 2021.
They've been a Connect customer since 2022
and have found great results
in providing their live agents
with good interaction
details for their customers
in these live call-handling situations.
They're able to use,
both the data that flows
through their systems
to make sure all their agents
have the right information
at the right time,
and they're also able to use
Connect's conversational analytics
to analyze the customer sentiment
so that they're able to have
their human agents understand
the intent of the caller
and make sure they deliver
the most empathetic
and accurate responses with accuracy.
Now my wife, she's actually
a very loyal Sak's customer.
So often she'll buy 10 dresses
online, try 'em all out,
pick two to keep,
I take the eighth to return
to the physical location.
I come back home, there's 10 more boxes,
rinse, cycle, repeat.
And ultimately, this is kind
of a problem for myself,
but great for her.
She has no problem.
And the few times that she's
ever had to call in for help,
they've been resolved so
smoothly and seamlessly,
it just maintained her loyalty throughout.
And this type of smooth,
seamless, personalized engagement
is also what GoStudent's can
provide for their customers.
Now, GoStudent is a little bit further
than East Fifth Avenue to
the east, based in Europe.
They are a continental provider
of tutoring via online resources,
and they use customer
profiles from Connect today
in order to help engage their customers
with the right accurate responses.
And the way they do this
is they're able to use
customer profiles to understand
where the customer came from,
their past interactions,
and make sure they make
the right routing decision
of how to hook them up
with the right specialist
to help engage 'em for their topic.
Ultimately, this has helped
them with their conversions
of getting new clients,
and they're now looking to
combine customer profiles
with their outbound
engagement capabilities
in order to go through their
leads list of potential clients
and using AI to filter
through many common questions and topics
before a contact ever
reached a human agent,
in order to speed up the process
of converting them to a sale.
And so ultimately, GoStudent believes
they can increase their
agent productivity by 20%,
handling that many more conversions
through this combination
of an outbound engagement
with our customer profiles
for more personalized experiences.
Now, they're a pretty good
example of, just like Saks,
they started off with a inbound
contact center use case,
but they're transitioning
now to also expand
and enhance with outbound engagement.
And this is sort of very synonymous,
the journey of Connect overall.
Probably many of you
have started with Connect
as a contact center,
but ultimately, it is just a
customer engagement platform
that helps you deliver
personalized experiences
wherever your customer is.
Now moving even further east then Europe,
we're gonna talk about Snoonu.
They are a leading
e-commerce platform in Qatar,
and they focus on delivery services.
They help with grocery
deliveries, food deliveries,
as well as pharmaceutical products
among many other business services.
And they've used AWS overall
for their personalization AI,
and which help boost
their ROI by 47%, 47x.
But additionally,
they're now looking to use
those personalized recipes,
those personalized AI models
we talked about before,
in order to even go a step further
in improving their
conversion rates for sales.
And so this is what it looks like for them
for two possible use cases exploring now,
is one will be proactive
suggestions of reorders,
looking at the customer's
purchase history,
the timing of it, and
making proactive suggestions
of "Hey, you should order this again"
or potentially making
this a recurrent purchase.
And additionally, the cross-sell use case,
given their platform nature
and their why types of
products they can sell
and deliver to their customers,
they're gonna have AI
models from our product,
they'll span and look
across different merchants,
different business services,
define the right cross-sell opportunities
at the right time for their customers
in order to maximize that customer value,
and honestly, meet the
customer in a better situation
with more seamless
transactions and deliveries.
And so this is a combination
of what's already in structure today
and what is coming out
just now as of this week.
Now the last example we
provide is United Airlines.
They've been a long time AWS customer,
and in 2024, they went under a project
to upgrade their media service.
And in the process,
they noticed that their existing
custom entity resolution
for customer profiles,
that was an on-prem system,
was having some issues with
quality and durability,
and ultimately had led to a duplication
of 15% of their loyal customers' accounts.
So ultimately, they had
to go through a process
of figuring out how to clean that up.
And initially, after they
scanned this for just loyal,
they found out there was
problems across the whole base,
and they ultimately
settled on Amazon Connect
and Amazon Connect Entity Resolution.
With this entity resolution capability,
which is an AI feature that
scans different accounts,
resolves duplicates, and makes
a complete centralized set,
they're able to reduce
their duplicate entries
for all users by 35%.
And additionally, in
the process of migrating
from on-prem to the cloud,
reduce infrastructure costs by 30%.
And this is all from the
features that predate re:Invent,
but I will mention a
quote later on from United
of one of our new upcoming features
that just launched this week.
So speaking of launches this week,
normally when we talk about,
in these presentations,
the new features that come out,
there's maybe three or four,
and we dive deep into them.
But this year's a little bit trickier
because we actually accelerated
our feature delivery velocity
and now have 30 features
that came out this week
as part of Connect.
And each of them, whether
directly or indirectly,
touch on personalized experiences.
So to maximize the time we have,
we've only cherry-picked
about nine of them,
and we'll walk through
different categories of them.
Now the main common theme between them
is they do ultimately tie to agentic AI.
Ultimately, this is the trend
that's going through the world,
and very much so in the
industry of customer service.
And likewise, for Connect,
it's a very powerful
step function improvement
in what you can do.
Now in many ways, some of these features
are new AI technologies for automation,
a step function improvement
in what you can achieve
and what you can simulate.
But additionally, as part of Connect,
we really just view it as software,
another step in a journey
of creating better outcomes for customers.
As such, all these
features around agentic AI
span across all of Connect,
all the different features we talk about,
outbound, inbound, different personas,
they just weave throughout.
So the four buckets we'll focus on
have to do with AI actions,
the real-time engagement
with customers and employees
and how AI helps there.
Additionally, how beyond automation
AI can help your workforce
improve their skill sets
and solve harder problems
and uplevel faster.
The third category is really
about taking all the data
that flows through your
business and your contact center
and using it to transform that data
into meaningful customer relationships.
And lastly, a pillar for how
to accelerate your outcomes
using all the analytics
and insights that we can provide you.
So this is gonna be a lot of material,
and I'll go slow, not rush through it,
but not take too long.
I just have three
takeaways before I dive in.
There's only three things
to remember from this deck.
For this part of the deck,
I'd recommend just one,
we have AI agents in Connect.
They're out-of-the-box agents,
but also customizable to
meet your business needs.
As such, you can, two, personalize them
to your customer experience
so that you can make every interaction
have a nice tailored touch.
And three, we do have
out-of-the-box features
around personalization
to make it easier and lower that lift.
So starting from the top,
AI agents in Connect.
This is something we've been working on
over the past year,
and now we have a rounded-out solution
where our previous agents
that provided the its
assistance in self-service,
and human assistance,
more informational-based,
can now take actions.
They're able to take an input
and provide that output
by acting on environment
on behalf of the end user.
Now as part of this,
they're also able to retrieve
the right information,
and as such,
make it a very personalized
tailored experience.
But it also gives you the flexibility
to just make sure these
agents can automate the steps
you need to.
Now as part of this,
it's generative AI-based,
all empowered, but we have
taken a stance with Connect
to really allow you to
have deterministic flows
where you need them.
I'll touch about this a little bit more,
but there is this notion of
using flows in our flow modules
in order to interweave
deterministic workflows
where you need it,
or just when you're
choosing to go full agentic,
it's up to you.
One last call-out,
'cause it won't be the rest of the section
in terms of collaborating with agents
that might live elsewhere
in your enterprise,
this type of multi-agent collaboration,
as of today, we support
the collaboration of agents
via third-party MCP tools.
So, out-of-the-box agents,
I alluded to before,
we have some existing agents
for self-service and
human agent assistance,
and we've extended those, as of this week,
can now provide action automation.
These actions can be completing,
updating transaction, systems of record,
but also retrieving
information autonomously
from disparate sources.
But additionally, as part of
these out-of-the-box agents,
we also have a slew of new ones,
such as case summarization,
cast recommendation, and
a preview announcement
of a agent-scheduling, forecasting agent.
And ultimately, this is
just a showcase that,
as part of Connect,
we really view AI agents
as just another feature,
and one that for any of these
different types of workloads,
we're gonna provide ways to
enhance those experiences
in as turnkey a manner as possible
since Connect is first
an AI match solution
that does still allow
for interoperability.
So I wanna preface with this slide first
just 'cause these are
the agents we have now.
And there'll be many more
in just part of our overall strategy,
but now I'm gonna turn
to some customizations.
These will be the most
technical slides in the deck.
But since these have
been the most common asks
we've had from a lot of
customers, some of the audience,
I wanna make sure we call them out.
The first one, the most technical slide,
is about Model Context Protocol support.
As of this week, we
officially support MCP,
the framework for Anthropic,
that really provides a standardized way
for AI agents to take actions
and retrieve information.
As part of this launch,
we have some tools,
LM tools that use MCP protocol,
and they're provided out of the box.
These include the ability to
have an agent create a case,
update a case, start a task,
retrieve customer profile
information and insights,
and many more.
But additionally, we also,
maybe most importantly
for model customers,
apply the ability to have
third-party tool integrations.
Now this is all powered
from Amazon Bedrock Agentcore Gateway.
This way you have the ability
to set up servers
throughout your enterprise,
whether your own division
or sister divisions.
And you'll have the confidence
that you can take these tools
and integrate into your contact center
when and where you need them,
whether it's for the constant AI agent use
or even just for occasional
lookups where it might be.
Now, in the middle between
first party and third party,
I do wanna call out for those
existing kind of customers
that we have taking flow modules,
and we have turned them
into tools as well.
So you have the option to
go through your flow modules
and just hit a button and add them
to your own MCP server,
post it by Connect.
And the reason why we did this is, one,
we noticed that the schema
is pretty much the same.
There's inputs, there's
outputs through subscriptions,
so why not make them tools?
And two, it gives you the ability
to build business logic once,
and whether used in a static workflow,
human-led step by step guide,
or an agentic workload, reuse it.
Ability to build once and
reuse wherever, whenever.
Additionally, in order to
do third-party integrations,
this also gives you the affordance
to keep using your Lambda blocks
for data dips and transactions
as part of an agentic workflow in Connect.
Now, this is the main
customization that is new.
You can take your out-of-the-box agents,
tailor them how you like,
add different tools that
meet your business needs,
make your own tools.
But this is all part of the bigger picture
about how we let you customize
the agents that live in Connect.
And so these customizations
start at the prompt level.
For those who don't know, for
all the out-of-the-box agents,
for self-service and
human-led interactions,
we expose our prompts so that,
A, you see where they are,
but B, you can actually go
in and tweak a little bit,
or C, delete and rewrite your own.
This really lets you
tailor these AI agents
to your use cases and your unique needs.
And ultimately, adding
your knowledge bases,
multiple to each agent now, as
well as uppercase guardrails,
such as PI redaction, content filtering.
As well as the tools we just mentioned,
this ultimately is just
the different capabilities
you might need to
personalize the experience.
This way the AI agents that you deploy
ultimately know any information
you need to know about the customer,
know at the right time, dig deep.
And wherever the data lives,
these agents can extract it,
pull it in, and provide
the right reasoning
for action execution,
action recommendation,
and just providing personalized help.
So this is a sort of key part of Connect,
just the ability to
customize these agents.
And before I move on and to
the last technical slides,
I just have to call out
that although we have built
on top of AWS AI services
for these features,
it helps us move faster and
move at the rate of AWS,
we also have though provided
our open model selection,
we're relatively agnostic.
So as of today,
you can choose between
the Amazon Nova family
as well as the Anthropic Claude family,
up to Sonnet 4.5 later this week.
So a lot of these, for
instance, we've talked about,
really do lend itself really well,
and customer self-service,
not featured in the stack,
but as part of the Connect launches.
We have a Amazon Connect
Nova Sonic integration
that really allows for these
human sounding engagements,
that while not personalized
strictly in the data
that comes from the reasoning part,
it really provides this
human-centered interaction
that makes the customer feel
really sort of cared for.
Now, this is a huge step function,
what you can do for self-service,
but this is not the only place
that AI agents extend to.
And very important to us
that you have this ability
to take these AI agents
and use it to augment
your human workforce.
And so as a key pillar
of just how we've approached
AI agents in Connect
is this ability to not just interoperate
between your APIs, what agents can do,
but interoperate between
what workloads your humans
do and what your agents do.
So already before today
you had the ability
to pick when and where
to deploy an AI agent,
whether it's at the start of a contact,
maybe just an offshoot for some Q & A.
And also, likewise, it can be the choice
of when does that AI
agent maybe loop a human
into the conversation.
This could be via asynchronous tasks
that it needs for back office
approval before proceeding,
or it could be just escalate to a human
with our escalate to
human out-of-the-box tool.
And so this gives you the ability
to sort of pick and choose
and design your experiences
of how to blend AI with human workloads,
but ultimately, it allows you
to help them work in concert.
But having them work in concert
doesn't end once a contact is transferred.
Once a human actually,
employee has the contact,
we have the ability to
provide an AI agent assistant
that helps them guide them all
the way through the contact
or just recommendations for key pieces
of conversational turns.
And so what's new from
what we didn't have before
is this ability of task automation.
Now the AI assistant is able
to do back office backend work,
just execute transactions, look
up information dynamically,
all in the vein of autonomous reasoning,
as AI agents are likely prone to do.
But additionally, we've
enhanced the ability
to provide step-by-step guidance.
So whether it's a start of the
contact providing an overview
of what the human agent should do,
or dynamically in the interaction,
providing suggestions.
So maybe your IVR
is providing really good
information gathering
of what the contact's about,
routing to the right agent,
give 'em a nice summary and a static view.
But it turns out that this
customer has a second intent,
a second topic,
or just in order to solve
the primary problem,
just a little bit extra information
about a purchase order
history needs to be retrieved,
maybe for warranty considerations.
Before today, using Connect in particular,
you would have to program it
so that a human agent
clicks through many screens,
maybe 10, just to find
the right information,
tell the customer to wait
on hold as they gather it.
But now the AI agent can autonomously
just gather information,
populate to the agent.
And this way the human
agent can really focus
on talking to the
customer, being empathetic,
and doing things that humans are best at.
So these are, what I just presented,
are really, in many ways, foundational.
But there is a question now again,
well, what about personalization?
Yes, these agents can automate actions,
and it's very transactional,
but what about going back to the ability
of personalizing things?
And for this and our new capabilities,
a lot of centers on these
predictive insights,
not just having Connect as a ability
to sort of populate
just static information,
but really help generate ways
to find improvements in your workloads.
So, what I showed before is
really how you can customize
what we provide to bring in your data,
which is still very true and apt,
but now I'm gonna focus
on things you can now do
out of the box.
And that goes back to one
of the earlier slides we had
about our predictive insights
based on our own Amazon
personalization models.
These models work from out of the box,
and for each of them,
we have tools to let you
gather those insights
at any time in an interaction.
And so as part of this, there
are five models in particular,
and they really lend themselves well
to that cross-sell use
case or upsell use case,
wherever it's a chance to find
a better OI in a customer,
delivering to them what they need,
and maybe things they
didn't know they needed.
But additionally, one
thing I sort of hinted at
is while we have these as tools
and they could use at
any point of interaction,
what I mean is, whether
it's a static workflow
or generative, you're able
to leverage these insights.
So the AI agent can do it just
tool calling at any moment.
It's autonomous actor,
they can get the insight,
then make a suggestion
directly to the end customer
or to a human colleague.
But even in your workflows
and Connect contact flows,
you're able to query for these insights
and decide with conditional rules,
"Okay, we have insight, let's populate it.
Or no insight, let's move on."
And really add rules to that flavor.
You can really get a chance
to both get these automatic insights
but still tailor to your user journey
that makes sense for your business.
And by journey, this really blends well
with our latest re:Invent
launch for app bank campaigns,
customer journeys.
Traditionally, with Connect,
our app bank campaigns,
were focused on one customer
touchpoint, one channel.
But as of now, as of two days ago,
you can now design an
entire customer journey,
whatever interaction might
be for proactive engagement.
Now these can be cross channel,
our newest channel of support is WhatsApp,
and you're able to filter in
different conditional rules,
weight, logic, follow ups,
whatever makes sense for your journey,
you can now build in Connect, both API,
but maybe more importantly
from our visual designer
that is very much akin
to our our existing visual
designer in Connect.
So you have just one workflow experience
no matter what type of engagement
you're trying to build,
inbound or outbound.
So ultimately, this really
gives you the control you need
to reach out to customers proactively.
Since again, Amazon Connect
is really just about customer engagement,
whether inbound or outbound,
but also gives you the hooks
to just use REI models.
Whether you're gonna lean
into agentic AI or not,
these AI is there for you for
a non-agentic world still.
So now I wanna come back to
the United quote I mentioned before.
And so besides using existing technology
for the results I showed before,
they do plan to use these
personalizing capabilities
with customer profiles,
deliver better outcomes.
Ultimately, they use
customer profiles today
to get that complete
customer understanding.
And then, now I wanna
take that understanding,
user out-of-the-box AI,
to deliver better proactive engagement
every step of the way
of a customer journey.
And so the example that
they're looking at right now,
they're trying to implement,
has to do with pre-ordering meals.
That way before a customer
is opening up their app,
maybe busy running to the airport,
there's already a proactive suggestion
of what meal they might wanna order
based on their previous
history inclination to buy,
and maybe some other
insights about that customer.
So this is an exciting opportunity
for one of the world's largest
airlines to take advantage
of one of the world's largest
customer engagement platforms.
But personally, I'm very excited
since I'm based in New York,
I fly out New York all
the time, a hub of United,
so I personally plan to take advantage
of whatever proactive recommendations
they come out with, very selfishly.
Now the last section of our new features
that we're gonna cover
has to do about how do you
manage all these AI capabilities,
and in particular, these new
autonomous AI agent actors,
these AI agent workers.
And so when it comes to this,
maybe a dilemma for some
or opportunity for others,
we really view these AI agents
as just another worker, a virtual worker.
And whether you're managing a workload
that's gonna be human-led
or AI-led or mixed,
what matters most are the outcomes.
You're building a customer journey
and you're measuring it
against customer outcomes,
customer KPIs, and everything else
is ultimately just an
implementation detail.
So as such, when we view this in Connect,
we've, throughout the system,
whenever we had an opportunity,
we're taking existing Connect
features and reusing them
to apply to managing AI agent workloads.
And now the most notable one has to do
with what we showed before,
and that's agent evaluations.
Traditionally, this is
human agent evaluations,
and now it applies to
AI agent evaluations,
but in particular, it actually applies
to any self-service interaction.
So whether it's a human-led
interaction, self-service,
structured self-service,
like our traditional XPOS
or a fully generative AI
agent that does everything,
you ultimately can use
the same survey forms
with the same customer
outcomes of CSAT scores,
resolution rates, reopen rates.
Was the worker empathetic
enough? Were they accurate?
Just take those same scoring
to a contact and reapplied.
This gives a, one, easy way to use Connect
to do any workload,
but two, it also does give a way to tease
and phase out your agentic onboardings
since you can easily compare
how well AI agents work
compared to a human worker.
Now for this, we will provide, in general,
some proactive insights into like,
"Hey, we think this workload
could be automated."
A lot of this will come
through our new supervisor
Connect assistant
that has been preview announced,
but ultimately, we just
wanna give into your control,
the customer's control,
that ability to govern,
"Okay, when is the time to
move a workload to agentic?"
Maybe it's just routing
some contact percentage
to an AI agent.
Maybe it's the full contact.
Either way helps you decide
where humans are best,
and also, if you have any potential issues
with retention and attrition,
it makes you a decision
of when do you start
hiring more virtual workers
versus human workers to
handle repetitive workloads.
Additionally though,
there are times where some
things are unique to AI agents,
and we still have that end,
the traditional, canonical
AI agent observability.
And so these were shown
in those dashboards
in the last part of the demo.
And for this, we'll provide insights
in what your agents are
doing, how accurate they were,
if they're using knowledge bases,
what articles are recurring, how often,
and really providing you the insights
on what are the virtual workers doing.
Now this gives you the same
audibility as human agents.
In fact, for every contact record now,
you don't just see what AI
human agent was on the contact.
You'll now see what AI
agent was on the contact,
and even the tracing of
"What do the agents say?
What do they do?"
This way, again, regardless
of the the workload
and how you deployed it,
the contact records are source of truth
of what happened no
matter who the worker is.
Now, one of the benefits of AI agents
is that it's still a machine,
and to the best of anyone's abilities,
we'll be able to peel apart,
"Okay, well, why'd you say that AI agent?
What was your reasoning? What
was your thought process?
Give us your train of thought."
Something that's a little
bit harder with humans.
We're not always gonna explain ourselves,
and definitely not at scale.
So those are things
that will probably be unique to AI agents,
and we're always gonna
invest in that ability
to make sure you get
the same observability
you expect outside of Connect.
It'll to be part of Connect, since again,
AI agents is just another
feature in Connect.
But to that point though, we
do find a lot of commonalities,
again, in how you measure
agent performance,
whether human or AI.
So on that note, even something
like hallucination rates,
while we will have it for AI agents,
it's probably something we're
gonna look at for humans,
'cause I could have made
up a lot of things today,
who would know?
But we would have the same
scoring criteria to govern that.
'Cause ultimately, it's just
like about the final outcome,
the final results.
So with that, that's all we
had to share from today's deck.
And so any call to action,
I would say that with all
these new capabilities
we have launched this week,
as well as the ones we had before,
just recommend, give
them a shot, try it out.
These new agent workloads
really opens up a lot of doors,
and there's no better way
to see what works for you
than trying out our new
personalization models
and seeing what you think,
and providing us feedback.
So thank you for your
time, and if you have time,
it'd be great if you open up your app
and provide us feedback via the survey.
And for those who have any
questions or follow ups,
we'll be outta the hallway
taking any questions whatsoever,
whether it's about this
presentation to cover today
or anything else about Connect.
Thank you for your time.
- Yeah, thank you. Thanks a lot.
(audience applauding)